does the two thousand dollar m1 max max
studio have a much worse cooling system
than the 4 000 to 8 000
m1 ultra dang that's heavy well today we
will find out on friday we showed you
guys the full breakdown of the high-end
mac studio and its massive cooling
solution that is dual sided as well as
the m1 ultra soc that is massive
that thing is super impressive and you
know the thermals are insanely good it
literally doesn't want to go above 60
celsius no matter what you throw at it
today we will find out if this one
is just as good because we know that
this actually uses an aluminum cooling
system that weighs two pounds less so
i'm curious one what does it look like
is the heat sink much smaller do we have
one fan or two fans also afterwards we
are gonna look at the actual thermal
performance what temperatures we get
when we are maxing out the cpu when
we're maxing a gpu and if you're doing a
task that maxes out both is it gonna get
really hot above 90 degrees celsius just
like the m1 max in the macbooks or does
that still perform pretty well even
though it has a much lighter uh and less
expensive cooling system enough talking
let's go ahead and get into this so that
ring came off much more cleanly than the
last one if you guys ever do this please
be very careful because the power supply
is exposed you can get hurt make sure
all the power is drained out
do not touch it do this at your own risk
apple does not want you to be taking
this apart and take a look at that guys
the ssd is still socketed and we do
still have that extra slot on the other
side this is the base model with 512
gigs of ssd i'm not certain but i assume
that everything up to the two terabyte
model comes with one ssd
and then if you get the four terabyte or
the eight it will come with two because
it needs that extra density and because
those are actually the fastest
performing ones they're both similar all
right guys look at that we definitely
have a different cooler design than the
m1 ultra the heatsink is different the
way it mounts is different looks like a
much smaller assembly and instead of
having heat pipes on the back side as
well those two heat pipes it literally
just has a few little heat sinks right
here it looks like a nice mini version
of that but let's go ahead and check out
the actual full heatsink assembly and
the fans now it's helpful to know what
i'm doing this time i know that i have
to take everything apart and if you guys
appreciate the efforts please go check
out our m1 ultra shirts we have some
older ones as well you can use the
purple code m1 ultra for 20 off we would
definitely appreciate it now one
interesting thing that i noticed is that
the ssd
is actually on the other side this time
on the right side instead of the left
which means that i actually don't have
to remove it in order to take everything
else apart and get rid of these front
usb type-c ports i want to also let you
guys know that i did put together the m1
ultra i know a lot of you guys talked
about it that mac studio uh took about
an hour and it was really detailed but
everything works just fine all right
guys i got all of those ports out of
there now it's time to break
the heatsink free that's what holds it
down to the frame
and now for the moment of truth let's
see if i learned from the previous one
and if i did all of this correctly it is
definitely way way lighter than the
ultra alright it's coming out
and
bam
there she is look at that guys
i don't know does it look basically the
same
looks very similar
i mean it is no longer front heavy
though the other one it would just
literally want to topple over so this
one's way more balanced now we have you
know the fans up here
we have uh as far as fins i don't know
maybe a little bit less dense maybe it's
identical probably identical let's go
ahead and
take these fans off here
all right
once again we have that wire that goes
all the way across just so it plugs in
on the other side i'm not going to be
unscrewing that and take a look at this
guys look at these heat pipes right over
here that go on top of the chip and then
come into the cooler i don't remember
seeing that on the m1 ultra cooler that
is made out of copper i'll show some
b-roll footage here but i could be wrong
but i just don't remember seeing that
let's go ahead and take off this
heatsink oh man
i thought i was going to get away
without having to remove the ssd but it
looks like nope if you are going to be
working on a mac you can't get away with
it you still have to remove the ssd if
you want to get to that bottom screw and
now the very last thing holding this
heatsink together
all right guys moment of truth
all right
bam there we go wow
wow what is
this is interesting okay so look at that
we actually have
copper here your actual plate thermal
plate here for the heatsink it is made
out of copper but then we have aluminum
on the sides it looks like for the
memory if you guys see that it has a
different thermal paste than what we
have here in the center has the same
black thermal paste that we had on the
heat pipe section that split up to the
back with the m1 ultra and let's take a
look at the m1 max
interesting
wow okay
very cool
you guys see right there we actually see
the
memory modules the ram that's why it's a
different thermal paste on here
and the actual soldered lid for the m1
max does not cover the whole chip like
it did with the ultra
it just covers the actual uh m1 max
right there
and then you know the components that
are built in but their memory is
separate that's so interesting and then
we have this ring right here
where it literally shows you the size of
the m1 ultra die
look how much larger it is so this whole
motherboard looks very empty compared to
the previous one
uh everything's just so much smaller
less components of course do not have
the heat pipe some stuff's rearranged
but look at that size difference of the
m1 ultra on the outside which is
completely closed off versus this one
where we see those memory modules and
now the question is
does this aluminum heatsink with the
dual fans
and this different thermal setup a much
smaller die
doesn't keep the system as cool as the
fully copper version that i don't
believe has the heat pipes
and it's all solid copper
well let's go ahead and take a look
alright guys so now let's go ahead and
take a look at the temperatures that we
get with this cooling system and the m1
max chip now i'm gonna go ahead and open
up tg fan pro we'll have a link down in
the video description and they literally
just updated this to actually show all
the performance cores we have the
efficiency cores the gpu clusters
airflow sensors memory bank there's 32
gigs of ram all the ports that is
amazing now the first thing i'm paying
attention to is the fan speed and as you
guys can see we're still running at 3
500 rpms max with a baseline 1100 rpms
for the slowest speed but as you guys
can see apple they are running this
these fans at 13 26 13 27 they don't run
it at idle just like the m1 ultra we're
gonna be comparing temps to that one
let's open up cinebench here we are
gonna do the 10 minute stress test bam
let's go ahead and get started now we
have a baseline about 33 degrees celsius
right away we jumped up to 41 50 52
okay let's see if it stays there uh with
the m1 ultra and that copper cooling
system it pretty much stayed at 49.50 it
was super low uh lower than this and the
fans stayed at idle the whole time we're
gonna see with the stress test is it
gonna keep heating up and have those
fans ramp up and if this is
a cooling system that is not as good as
the ultra now i know what some of you
guys are going to say down in the
comments hey you took this mac studio
apart what if you didn't do a good job
what if the results aren't correct well
i'm actually doing this test before i
took it apart to make sure that i did
not mess anything up and the results are
correct now you also would need to know
that this is the base model
but the cpu setup and the wattage in the
course it's identical to the one that
you can spend 200 extra for and upgrade
to extra graphics cores now we're going
to run this we're going to run graphics
and then we're going to run both of them
at the same time to see what kind of
temps we get if you're just maxing out
both the cpu and the gpu and if we go
ahead and hit those higher temps
like we do with the macbooks all right
guys it has been just over five minutes
and we are at 59 degrees celsius right
now
still super cool and that is the hottest
core and then as far as fans let's take
a look here
basically just above idle a tiny bit
above idle now with the m1 ultra the
highest end chip 20 course double the
cores it actually ran at 58 degrees
celsius if you guys look right here it
actually just went down to 58 degrees
celsius so it looks like even though the
cooler is made out of aluminum not
copper and it weighs 2 pounds less
the temperatures are still rock solid
it's like apple's tuning this for 58 59
degrees celsius practically the same
even though with our older intel max
these things would be running at 9 500
degrees celsius so apple could probably
shut off the fans of running right at
idle or shut one off but they're not
they're actually running them slightly
above idle so our 10 minutes are out
we're finishing for the last loop over
here and we're still running at 59 it
just hit 60 when i'm moving stuff around
back down to 59 degrees celsius this
means that if you're doing cpu tasks
xcode rendering photo editing exporting
thousands of images
logic anything you do this system will
be completely silent and here we go we
have a score of 12
310
and right when we got done it literally
just instantly dropped down to 38
degrees celsius and now assess that the
graphics i have 3d marks wildlife
extreme with the unlimited mode so it's
off screen should not be limited by the
refresh rate or anything like that and
let's see what kind of temperatures we
get our graphics card has been maxed out
cpu is at 24 so it is doing stuff
44 degrees celsius is the highest that
we see that is pretty crazy most
graphics cards don't even idle that low
and now let's push this machine to its
limits we're going to start up cinebench
we're going to max out the cpus right
there bam our cpu is maxed out i'm gonna
wait till the cpu hits that 59 degrees
celsius its hottest point which is mind
blowing and then we're gonna kick in 3d
marks extreme stress test as well
alright guys we've been running for
about 20 seconds or so
and this is very interesting first off
the cpu literally went from 58 degrees
celsius 59 now it's just steady at 60
degrees celsius the graphics look at
this 42 the hottest core the hardest
cluster of course
insanity our cpu is maxed out now if you
take a look at something i just made a
discovery
the gpu is not maxed out it's running at
74 percent of its performance compared
to 100 before now if you guys remember
with the laptop videos we did we found
that if you're maxing out the cpu gp at
once it throttles the system
down it literally throttles the
frequency of
the graphics now i thought that was
because of thermal limitations because
it was literally running really hot when
you're doing that the fans that's when
you really got the fans to spin up but
here we're running at six degrees
celsius literally is not budging 43
degrees celsius 40 back to 42 on the gpu
it doesn't care
but apple is still limiting the graphics
performance even though we have no
battery issues we are plugged into power
and
there are no temp issues this thing is
running insanely cool look 44 degrees
celsius right now is still running 60 61
degrees as far as the cpu and the fans
are literally basically at idle that is
in
sanity so this proves one that there's
definitely power limitations in play
we're going to be exploring that in
future videos and getting to the bottom
of this and two that no
the m1 max chips
they do not throttle they do not get hot
the fans don't spin up even if you max
out the cpu and max out at least as much
as you can the graphics performance that
is just blowing my mind so there you
guys go you guys got to look at the
inside of the m1 max max studio we got
to see how it compares to the previous
teardown that we did with the m1 ultra
and how the thermal performance
basically axe which is shockingly
shockingly good
wow i am impressed and also disappointed
as far as the graphics not reaching its
full potential if the cpu is maxed out
and we'll see how that
will affect some real world tests that
do actually max out the cpu and the
graphics so thank you guys for watching
make sure you guys click above to
subscribe we have so many awesome videos
coming up check out one of those videos
right over there if you haven't seen it
yet so max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]